oh hey how's it going yeah welcome to
the live cocoa camp event here we go it
is 3 a.m. and news the stand-up showcase
all right know what's going on you're
here with us you're here with us and it
is goodies our comedy club so if you
could at home do your best to simulate a
comedy club lights at home lower them
down if you got a loved one nearby have
them bring you a beverage
and please tip them well because because
we love our servers and there is a
two-drink minimum at home and we got
some great stand-up but let's give it up
for our in-house studio all right now
here's the deal we're coming to you from
Burbank which is part of the Los Angeles
area and part of what we are on is
you're familiar with the TV show the
hills there's the hill and we are just
feet away from Hollywood
technically in theory we are Hollywood
it's a geographical issue but for those
who don't know about Hollywood I'd like
to give you a few tips little things to
know I like to call this Hollywood
rumors let you know about what people
are talking about in Hollywood so you
can kind of get it going - with
Hollywood yeah alright so here we go
alright so here's here's a these are
some actual factoid rumors that are
going on Hollywood gossip here we go
alright did you know this that this was
in the trades in the in the Ruhr column
Glee is dedicating entire episode to the
subway five-dollar footlongs oh it's
true as far as rumors go it's true 9 out
of 10 Biggest Loser contestants are
played by Eddie Murphy put your hands
together for you come with Brad Pitt
lately again sir
[Applause]
alright this won't be awkward at all
how's it going one guy who's here and
fewer people watching at home great good
night visit I know that our lead in here
was like four hours of even current
standing in a stairwell yes which is
almost as bad as our leaning at the last
Network uh yeah I've been look at some
of the comments you guys have been
posting underneath all day they've been
that some good some bad
most of them are like oh who's that girl
what's her name what's her name
they're all interns the staff doesn't
even know their name right yeah I'm new
exactly but yeah before I worked for
Conan I actually worked for the Maury
Povich Show where I had to take calls
from people who wanted to be in the
studio audience and now they weren't
much better than the guests like I got a
call from this one woman and she goes
I'd like to come see Maury but I live in
Dallas is New York far from Dallas as I
go to your window I'm waving oh I'm
Conan is known for being pale and let's
let's see what you had to say about it
Internet
all right Starkiller 2012 writes cut is
so pale the BIOS won't even claim him I
did not know that
elbows were organized but hey unions man
got it you know all right
toaster rodeo right Scott is so pale the
guy in the red shirt is super hot I
think you meant to say a red shirt or is
it red shorts are the rich who we talk
about
yeah ladies gentlemen one of the funny
skies around mr. Brent boring dude this
is the worst hour by the way it's 3:30
no one laughs at 3:30 or 6:30 no one
laughs serial killers at 3:30 and 6:30
normal people don't except for him who's
been here what do you go to school
University of Laverne when I say cool
like that that's what every guy does by
the way when I talk to a girl and she
gets in there like a major or whatever
she's doing cool we look away we never
make eye contact their lives
you